here's what would happen if these three  things disappeared for five seconds  removing the Sun for five seconds would  remove its gravitational influence which  would result in every planet Moon and  asteroid in our solar system starting to  fly off into outer space when the sun  returns it would grab hold of everything  again but that small shift in gravity  would cause Havoc throughout the solar  system if carbon disappeared for five  seconds you'd immediately lose 10 to 15  kilograms of your body mass since humans  are 18 carbon lastly If gravity on Earth  ceased to exist for five seconds people  cars and everything not attached to the  ground would start flying around  I hope you wouldn't float too high off  the ground because when gravity returned  you'd plunge straight down to the ground  so just five seconds can make a huge  impact you'd be super lucky to survive  these scenarios because